jeremy thank you for that well residents
in north las vegas area who live close
to the airport say this was one of their
worst fears having a plane crash so
close to their home as planes continue
to fly directly overhead victoria saha
joining us live with that angle victoria
yeah we spent majority of our morning
here trying to talk to residents who
live nearby and telling me what they see
coming in and out of this airport behind
me and they tell me after yesterday's
crash they're very concerned
the north las vegas airport is home to
many private planes and aviation
enthusiasts and with many flight schools
surrounding it it makes for a busy
airport for inbound and outbound flights
it's
all day long residents like dan dino
garcia living nearby sees planes flying
very close to his house and plane
crashes just like the one that occurred
sunday are a constant worry for him what
do you always think when you see a plane
so close to your house well hopefully
don't crash here they come almost
directly over my apartment maybe a
hundred feet hundred yards we have
uncovered the registration for two
planes involved in the sunday afternoon
crash according to the aviation safety
network the cessna skyhawk is registered
to binner enterprises llc which is
registered in henderson the piper plane
coming from idaho is owned by gold arrow
aviation which is registered to a las
vegas and a florida address
i have reached out to both companies but
still have not heard back again this
crash killed four people in two separate
planes we're still waiting for the
coroner to release their identities
victoria saha live local now